Ciao a tutti siamo Asia ho 18 anni e
appunto Da quando ne avevo 5 faccio
pattinaggio questo certamente non mi
rende in alcun modo una maestra di vita
però sono molto brava a dare consigli e
senza alcuna arroganza un consiglio
vorrei darlo anche a voi magari anche
più di uno e sono sempre stata una
persona fissata e con le parole dobbiamo
sempre dato molto peso e vorrei
riflettere insieme a voi più il
significato di queste cinque Gioia
sacrificio
coraggio
successo e passione che poi viste in
separata sede sono parole con
significati completamente differenti ma
se le vediamo tutte insieme magari
possono essere riferite alla stessa cosa
perché dalla gioia nasce quella
sensazione di
completezza di chi sta Vivendo a pieno
la propria vita e la vita si sa è fatta
da alti e da bassi e molto spesso sono
soltanto bassi e ci vuole coraggio per
affrontare certe situazioni e ci vuole
anche
c'è bisogno anche di fare dei sacrifici
e sacrificio dopo sacrificio si arriva
magari al successo e io non so dare
precisamente un significato a questa
parola perché fondamentalmente il
successo è relativo e magari è un
diploma una laurea è la statuetta
dell'oscar oppure è una sufficienza in
matematica o una un sei nella versione
di latino oppure sono tutti quei
biglietti che da quando sono piccola mi
vengono scritti al compleanno e che io
tengo ancora a tutti quanti dentro una
scatola sotto al letto perché il
successo è relativo e se oggi tu non sei
ancora andato in palestra ad ammazzarti
di piegamenti va bene lo stesso perché
magari tu tra un'ora avrai l'idea più
innovativa e originale della storia o
magari no perché comunque il successo è
relativo e siamo sempre allo stesso
bivio
nostra fama e fallimento A me
personalmente non interessa di nessuna
delle due perché mi basta che almeno una
persona mi ascolti Davvero E che in
quello che dico ci sia sentimento perché
è successo è relativo e magari è non
aver saltato il pranzo la cena o aver
mangiato quel pezzo di torta in più
oppure aver rimandato ancora per un
giorno perché magari ne vale la pena
aspettare un altro po' però
è sempre tutto nelle nostre mani Noi non
dobbiamo essere gli spettatori della
nostra vita dobbiamo diventare
protagonisti dobbiamo provare e
riprovare Certo che fa un po' ridere che
adesso vi sto dicendo questa cosa perché
io fino a qualche mese fa ero convinta
che se una cosa è destinata a noi trova
il modo di raggiungerci e spero di non
essere Comunque l'unica a pensarlo E
però non è così perché le occasioni ce
le creiamo noi e adesso ho capito che ho
sprecato Tanto tempo a voler ritagliare
perfettamente i bordi del foglio di
carta a cui ero convinta di essere
destinata quando sono arrivata alla
conclusione che tutti i fogli di carta
sono utili soltanto per fare un fuoco e
magari noi ci possiamo sedere tutti
vicini e scaldarci insieme perché magari
ad alcune persone quel fuoco basta
mentre ad altre no ed è lì che entra in
gioco la passione la passione è
l'esaltazione che interrompe La
monotonia quotidiana ed è difficile
trovare qualcosa che ti appassioni
perché è un viaggio che devi fare dentro
di te e non devi sentirti frustrato Se
non riesci a trovare ciò che ti piace
perché devi provare devi cascare e devi
rialzarti caschi cento volte ti rialzi
101 L'importante è che quindi non ti
fermi davanti alla prima difficoltà
appunto come ho detto all'inizio faccio
lo stesso sport da 13 anni e è bello da
dire perché ho un punto fermo ho un
punto di sfogo E lì ho trovato persone
con cui sto bene anche quando va tutto
male anche se non ne sento 24 ore al
giorno tutti i giorni Io so che lì posso
trovare qualcuno con cui sfogarmi con
cui ridere con cui piangere però se
raccontassi soltanto questa parte che è
la parte bella il mio discorso non
avrebbe senso in questo momento perché
volevo dirvi che non è stato facile ci
sono stati dei momenti in cui ho pensato
di voler mollare tutto perché vedevo
altre persone che sapevano fare molto
più di me e io non mi sentivo
all'altezza Io pensavo che magari
guardandomi intorno trovavo qualcosa di
più bello perché da fuori sembrava anche
più interessante e non dico che
guardarsi intorno È una cosa sbagliata
assolutamente magari questo discorso
fondamentale per me come non vale per
altre 10 persone però comunque
l'importante è non fermarsi la prima
difficoltà e soprattutto non fermarsi
quando non si ha più voglia perché
quando non si ha voglia si fa la
differenza perché quando tu hai voglia
di far qualcosa È normale che ti riesce
tutto se tu vai a scuola e hai tutti 10
Vai a casa è una famiglia che ti dà il
100% delle loro attenzioni c'hai la
ragazza e non ci litighi mai cioè il
ragazzo lo vedi tutti i giorni è normale
che ti viene voglia di fare le cose ma
quando tu sei a casa alle 9 di sera devi
fare un'ora e mezza di viaggio per due
ore di allenamenti di 20 dicembre con
meno 20 gradi
chi te lo fa fare potresti stare
benissimo a letto sotto le coperte a
guardare un film però ti fa la
differenza perché tu non fai quello che
vuoi ma fai ciò che serve per andare
avanti per formarti per andare sempre a
livelli superiori a Magari quelle
persone che ci sembravano fare qualcosa
di irraggiungibile Magari un giorno tu
potresti essere quella persona per
qualcun altro
ho sempre amato le persone che hanno una
passione per la vita che poi adesso mi
prenderete anche per Malta perché
nessuno fondamentalmente ha la passione
per la vita magari si hanno passioni per
cose diverse ed è così però comunque la
passione rimane quella la passione è
passione indifferentemente da se ti
piace la religione cavalli musica Sport
qualsiasi cosa basta che hai un qualcosa
che ti renda felice perché passione e
soddisfazione vanno di pari passo e
senza di queste la felicità non dura nel
tempo e
mi piace ascoltare le persone parlare
del loro argomento preferito Perché
dal luccichio che hanno negli occhi
percepisco la loro felicità e molto
spesso la felicità è contagiosa
e crescendo ha capito che arriva tardi
la felicità arriva tardi e se ne va via
presto e crescendo Ha capito anche che
non è come quando ero bambina che la
vedevo Come un qualcosa di così grande e
in realtà è soltanto ciò che di più
potentemente piccolo si infiltra nelle
cose grandi che sono piene di Fessure
perché la felicità è questa e ho capito
anche che tu vuoi essere felice in un
momento e l'attimo dopo subito triste
perché è normale barcamenarsi tra mille
sensazioni diverse e non capirci più
niente fino a che non ti esplode la
testa e infatti ho capito che non ha
senso stare ad aspettarla e non ha
neanche senso disperarsi se se ne va via
Perché
ho soltanto spiegato tempo
ehm
Infatti quando ero piccola e amavo fare
tante cose amavo vedere le persone
sorridere crescendo il sorriso un po' si
è spento perché ho capito tante altre
cose e quando si ha un muro grigio
davanti l'unica cosa che puoi fare è
immergersi nei pensieri e sperare che
non ti Mangino e con un muro Grigio non
intendo soltanto quello di camera mia e
il fatto è che
ho fatto una promessa alla media di 5
anni e anche se va tutto male anche se
ho questa voglia di mollare tutto Io
continuerò a scrivere cose belle sulla
sabbia Anche se il mare le porterà via
per sempre
[Applauso]